Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di "Cucina Buttata"
Si sa che uno dei dolci più famosi in italia è il tiramisù
che allo stesso tempo è uno dei dolci che la maggior parte delle persone dice di saper fare benissimo
poi li assaggi e fanno c****e
Ora siccome il tiramisù
è quel dolce che teoricamente riesce a
tutti quanti, mi sono detto perché non
fare una sfida in cucina e provare
a fare un tiramisù senza poter toccare con
le mani
nessuno degli ingredienti
Il che vuol dire
che potrò utilizzare cucchiaini, forbici
le stesse confezioni, l'importante è che
non sono a contatto con l'ingrediente
ma soprattutto per i passaggi più
complicati Titina la dinosaura
Avrò lui che è il mio assistente quindi in realtà quello che farò alla fine è una specie di T Rex Misù
Direi che possiamo partire. Vai!
E' inutile pure che ve lo dica per fare il tiramisù
servono
uova, zucchero, caffè, cacao in polvere, savoiardi
O non iniziamo con "No ci metti
i Pavesini, no ci metti i biscotti"
a me questa a me coi savoiardi fa c****e
Cioè preferisco con altre cose però volevo farlo tradizionale
e di base cioè non è che
faccia schifo se ci metti i savoiardi
e mascarpone, e un sacco di
caffettiere per fare il caffè
Quindi a questo punto viene di partire
con la sfida
Allora...ho aperto il caffè...non l'ho toccato
Il problema mio sapete
qual'è? E' che non so fare il caffè
Il male per quanto riguarda il caffè
Ok
Infiliamo
Cacchio!
A ma io non ho manco una
bilancia quindi oggi si fa a occhio
E piazziamo le prime tre caffettiere
una
due...Oddio!
Lei? Tre. Vebbè amen!
Tre
E mo divertiamoci ad aspettare
Erano usciti da tutti e quattro?
Cioè sono tre in realtà
Mamma mia uno qui non si può un attimo rilassare!
Uno, due. Ah vabbè dai è rimasto poco caffè (Chef Rico)
Questo ancora deve uscire
Tu hai stoppato tutto!
E ho capito ce stava la cucina in fiamme (Chef Mario)
Povero Purci ragazzi! (Chef Rico)
Vabbè gli...gli mettiamo tutto in ordine
Sta arrivando comunque m'ha scritto (Chef Mario)
Ne abbiamo tanto da qui
Qui?
Buono!
Mazza ragazzi la mossa di aver portato tutti quanti la
caffettiera da casa è stata la migliore
Non bisogna mai avere una cucina
sporca!
Specialmente se sta per arrivare il padrone di casa...Oddio!
Altro giro altra corsa
Uno...due...tre
Andiamo con un altro. Non posso
toccare non posso toccare un c***o
Ragazzi io non so nemmeno come si faccia così il caffè
Qual è il metodo
giusto per fare il caffè caffè'?
Ognuno lo fa come vuole in realtà il caffè (Chef Rico)
Però come fai a capire quando il caffè fa schifo e
quando buono. Cioè il mio so che fa schifo
E adesso è arrivato il momento di fare
la crema
Ti aiuto io!
Sembra un uovo di dinosauro che si schiude (Chef Mario)
Si sembra un momento magico
Ok. Ok aspetta è sceso il guscio
"Mmm bone le uova!" ...Bravo...mangialo!
Nel frattempo qui stiamo creando il
panico
Basta ragazzi è pieno all'orlo
Oddio
ragazzi io ho un problema!
Faccio due uova intere e una metto solo il
tuorlo
Capirai (Chef Rico). Capirai
Ok
Io devo prendere solamente il t... Oddio non devo toccarlo!... L' ho toccato
Devo prendere solamente il tuorlo
Capito lo faccio scolare
L'hai rotto! (Chef Rico)... L' ho rotto...Vero? Si...Eh sei condannato
Andiamo così...perché adesso
è comunque più tuorlo capito?
Si...si...si...si...si!
Passiamo allo zucchero...che sarebbero tipo un 130 grammi
Là là là
Stop!
Secondo me ci vuole più zucchero
Vuoi metterle? (Chef Rico)
No non solo sicuro. Il trucco è sbatterlo un sacco
che è un po un trucco in ogni cosa nella vita
Secondo me può andare
Aggiungiamo il mascarpone che grazie al cielo è già pesato perché ci servono 500 grammi
I mascarponi esistono per il tiramisù. Allora non devo toccare niente
A me me pare che stai a tocca tutto (Chef Rico). Io non sto toccando niente!
No non ce la fa
Mannaggia!
Ok!
Va bé
Ha fatto tipo l'effetto dello s*****o quando casca nel cesso (Chef Rico)
Credo abbia lo stesso sapore
Ora userò un'altra tecnica, si chiama la
tecnica "Giotto"
Tutto attorno come un un cerchio
in modo che poi con le stesse
forbici "Grey's anatomy"... togli tutto quanto
Grazie!
*imitazione rumori sul cesso* (Chef Rico)
Torniamo nella mia seconda cucina
Ok. Facciamo un piccolo... una piccola analisi
Più zucchero ragazzi
Prendiamo i savoiardi
Ho bisogno dell'aiuto di
Titina...sciacquiamole il  muso
*strana imitazione della colonna sonora di Jurassic Park*
Secondo me ho fatto così tanto caffè che cioè...che solo solo respirare quest'aria ci terrà svegli per un mese
Allora
Uno due... Nono!
Ah cacchio le sue zanne
diventano terribili per i savoiardi
Veloce veloce! (Chef Rico)
Si. Titina devi essere veloce!
*verso tirannosauro*
Titina! L'ho perso, l'ho perso
Titina salvalo!  Mamma mia!
Pazzesco! (Chef Rico)
Titina secondo me sto tiramisù viene così moscio e mollo che
Oddio
Nonono! (Chef Rico). Titina
L'hai perso. Noo è andato! (Chef Rico)
Titina. Titina. No Titina te ne stai nutrendo!
Non ti buttare giù Titina!
Apriamone un altro
Agguerrita. Agguerrita Titina
Ma veramente qual'è la tecnica migliore per inzuppare i savoiardi?
Cioè tipo deve essere a temperatura ambiente
deve fare uno, due,capito? Cioè hai presente che c'è chi conta, chi misura la temperatura del caffè
Vai Titina. NoTitina. No Titina. Titina l'hai perso
Titina, questo qua è veramente disgustoso questo che hai tirato fuori
Ok tac...tac...veloce
Più secco questo (Chef Rico)
Si...ma selo giro dall'altra parte non si nota niente
Questo pezzo è difficile ora per Titina perché...
devi inzuppare...inzuppare...dividere
Brava mangialo. Mangialo. Bravissima col colpo del feroce predatore
Comunque tu sei fortissimo ad usà sto coso eh! (Chef Rico)
Tu non hai capito io potrei essere un
tirannosauro
Io potrei avere una testa di tirannosauro al posto di questa mano. Me ne sono reso conto!
Secondo me è un...vedi? E' un po troppo...capito?
Titina pulisci tu col tuo...
Chiedo perdono a tutte quelle persone che sanno farlo il tiramisù
io perdonatemi con un dinosauro non ci riesco
Ok ok. Vai! Vai!
Sta gocciolando sul tavolo!(Chef Rico)
Ok scusatemi
E' vero l'ho toccato! L'ho toccato con la bocca!
Titina, sciacqua il tuo bel muso in quell'acqua salmastra
Dopo possiamo bruciarla. Questo qui non è un tiramisù, questa è una zuppa
Direi di spolverarlo subito con un po di cacao
Mamma mia il tiramisù comunque è tutto sul tavolo eh! (Chef Rico)
Questo è il mio T Rex Misù. Posso dirlo?
Un fallimento totale!
Questo con la cannuccia si prende
In teoria è pronto? (Chef Mario)
No! In teoria la cosa migliore ora è
metterlo in frigo...
Per?...Tre anni! (Chef Mario)
...e pregare
Il Purci ritrova in quel frigo dei mostri! (Chef Rico)
Ragazzi questa sfida finisce qui.
Fatemi sapere se anche voi ve l'accollerete
e proverete anche voi a cucinare un
tiramisù con un T rex
e quindi creare un bellissimo T Rex Misù!
Se avete dei
consigli per chi non sa fare il tiramisù
tipo me, credo l'unica persona in Italia a non saperlo fare o almeno ad ammettere di non saperlo fare
fatemelo sapere con delle foto o dei messaggi su Instagram o qua sotto
Io vi abbraccio e adesso pulirò tutta questa m***a
Quindi che dire! Ci vediamo la
prossima settimana sempre alle 12
Ciao